kappa getting for free died of a hole  there Adam Domenico the Hat  narrator I'm Domenico you air in the  nickel from Fred said he didn't go you  hurt people that I am demonic about what  change in the water temperature paradigm  chemical your muscles going in the  gorilla Pharaoh at the same time you  feel nothing and you're just black  [Music]  everything just melts away and  I enter a dreamlike world where I feel  weightless and that I could play  so desire Sabrina enjoyed chemistry type  the same damn economy that marine  creatures the metaphor occipital who  like and uh and then a political  progressive all the games internal  national but instead of looking outside  in look inside  because you're diving 101 breath put on  every second counts and every second is  magnified so you're really really just  in the moment  you  you  [Music]